we did a while ago we did a video on
portal 2 which is a fantastic game so
for people who haven't seen the game
before haven't played it well first of
all i recommend that you go and play it
really good game if you're interested at
all in physics so you have a portal gun
that allows you to to put portals holes
effectively that allow you to move from
one region of space to another region of
space you can put two of those portals
where you like you've got one portal
here for example and you could put
another portal here or you could put it
in the roof or you could put it in the
floor and that would allow you to move
between those you just walk into one
portal you come out the other so we can
put a portal here
i walk in like that and i walk out like
this
so
the question then is is my momentum
conserved my momentum no it's not my
momentum cannot be conserved here i walk
in my velocity vector is pointing that
way i walk through the portal and i walk
out this portal what's happened to my
velocity vector it's now pointing that
direction in the same frame of reference
i um you know the same coordinate system
i've walked in here with velocity vector
point in one way i've walked out here
with velocity vector pointing the other
way my momentum is fundamentally not
conserved it's just the same as if i
take this ball
and bounce it off the wall the momentum
of the ball in isolation is not
conserved but the momentum of the entire
system is conserved when i throw it at
the wall that the wall ever so
fractionally moves it's a big mass but
it ever so fractionally moves and the
momentum of the entire system is
conserved but that's not the argument in
portal 2 the argument in portal 2 is
that the momentum of the player the
character is conserved
which it fundamentally isn't so what is
conserved is velocity is a vector
quantity
speed is a scalar quantity it's a number
60 miles an hour whatever or 60
kilometers an hour so when i walk in the
portal
and then walk out the other side my
speed is conserved but my momentum isn't
what i love about 60 symbols what i
really love about 60 symbols on number
file and periodic videos is when you
look at those um common streams
um okay if you there are some silly
comments every now and again um but
there are some remarkably good arguments
on some remarkably um intelligent and
perceptive comments and i just see this
issue coming up time and time again and
because i'm just another youtube user i
don't own these channels i can go in and
i can say oh actually momentum isn't
conserved because of this
and then my comment will fall off the
bottom of the list and then another day
later it comes
and then you get tired of doing that so
i pleaded with brady please let me do
this so i won't have to type any more
comments in you're abusing your position
of power
yeah okay so the paul two makers done a
great job in making a fantastic game but
what we really need to do to make this
get the physics completely correct is
what we just say is that when we walk
through the portal there's some degree
of recoil or the the portal responds to
us and we can conserve momentum that way
so you walk through it and you get the
wibbly wobbly stuff you can back out
this side you get the wibbly wobbly
stuff and what's happening there with
the wibbly wobbly stuff and the blue um
the blue sheen and the blue light is
that
the
portal is reacting to you when you go
through it then the physics is all
correct the makers to the best of my
knowledge make the claim that the
momentum of the character is conserved
and anything that you shove through
the the portals that momentum is
conserved which is just fundamentally
not correct many times games are
criticized by being too violent and you
know leading our youth astray
and leading rather older people astray
as well
this is great it's
game has led to this type of discussion
fantastic
perhaps not in this context